the hawk fish is a brightly colored
orange spotted coral reef dwelling fish
with an incredible reproductive talent
hawkfish may begin their lives as
females but when there are too many
female hawk fish in their habitat they
have the ability to turn into males of
the same species this allows the new
male hawkfish to take on some of the
reproductive burden allowing the females
more mating options not only can the
hawkfish change its sex it can also
change it back a hawkfish that has
turned male can revert back to female if
the population makeup changes and more
females are needed this incredible
talent is not limited to hawkfish either
gender bending is prevalent throughout
the animal kingdom frogs bearded dragons
clownfish and many other animals have
the ability to change sex if the
situation calls for it you might be
sitting at home wondering what's with
all the animal talk i came here for an
scp video not a biology lesson well
trust us we're getting there while it's
simple for many other animals human
beings have a great deal more difficulty
changing their sex and gender
characteristics it can require surgery
and years of hormone replacement therapy
to get the kind of results a clownfish
gets overnight unless of course a human
gets their hands on
scp-113 scp-113 is a small polished red
stone resembling a piece of jasper when
studied closely in spite of its
resemblance it was found to not be
jasper or any other identifiable type of
rock when placed against the flesh of a
living thing with sex chromosomes the
organism's gender and sex-associated
physical characteristics are changed in
some way these effects were first tested
on humans with an unnamed d-class the
d-class was placed in a sterile
examination room and hooked up to a
variety of sensors and equipment
designed to monitor their biological
state health and any other changes to
their body that might take place first
the d-class was instructed to open their
hand and close the stone in their fist
this contact between their skin and
scp-113 kick-started the first stage of
the transformation process stage one
lasted approximately 0.2 seconds as the
stone bonded with the cells it was
touching causing a chemical change and
leaving a small amount of tissue damage
comparable to a mild burn as soon as
this process began the d-class could not
remove the stone from their hand
unsettled they attempted to shake the
stone loose from their skin but to no
avail it was firmly attached to the skin
and would not be removed until the
process was complete the second stage of
transformation followed lasting
approximately 20 seconds the d-class
reported feeling nauseous and promptly
vomited on the floor of the exam room
next they reported a stinging sensation
throughout their body like being pricked
with tiny needles all over these
sensations have been attributed to a
low-level electromagnetic wave released
by scp-113 during this phase which was
picked up by one of the monitors after
the nausea passed the scientists
observing the d-class's monitors began
taking furious notes shocked at what was
occurring though the modality of it was
unclear the subject's cellular makeup
was beginning to change some of their
cells were registering as non-human and
others were registering as human stem
cells at this point the d-class began to
scream in agony all of the sensory
nerves in their body were stimulated at
once and their brain activity was
overwhelming at a level similar to a
seizure finally once the screaming
stopped and the d-class had gone still
the rock came loose from their hand and
clattered to the floor after this a full
physical was performed and the d-class
was determined to have undergone
dramatic physical changes all of their
primary and secondary sexual
characteristics altered permanently
while scp-113's effect on humans with
binary gender identities male and female
have been studied it is still difficult
to determine the sort of impact that the
stone might have on someone with a
non-binary gender identity or if the
stone in fact takes gender identity into
account at all there is some evidence
that the stone is impacted by gender
identity though this is not always
consistent while scp-113 alters the
physiology of the test subject it has no
impact on the mind the subject's gender
identity remains the same before and
after testing with the stone in the case
of one intersex individual who was
exposed to the stone their secondary and
primary sex characteristics changed to
those that would be more affirming to
the individual's gender identity however
as this is still very inconsistent and
unpredictable not to mention possibly
accompanied by side effects that have
not been determined yet
scp-113 should not be considered a safe
or viable alternative to gender
confirmation surgery for transgender
individuals who might be seeking it for
the research is required on the subject
ordinarily it is standard scientific
practice to test on animals before
testing on humans however the scp
foundation isn't exactly known for its
standard research practices after
sufficient human trials have been
conducted the foundation researchers
studying scp-113 decided to test its
effects on other non-human organisms
there was a great deal of curiosity
about how it might impact various
animals especially those whose sexual
dimorphism or indeed entire relationship
to sex and gender is fundamentally
different from that of humans with
standard cats rats and dogs the impact
was essentially the same as that on
humans first the stone binds to the skin
then it emits an electromagnetic wave
causing some nausea and vomiting next
the sensory nerves are stimulated for 20
seconds as the cells become altered
finally the stone falls away from the
skin and the transformation has been
completed interesting at first but after
the 20th rat it starts to become a
little mundane however exposure of
certain other species to scp-113
resulted in some unusual effects when a
number of komodo dragons were exposed to
scp-113
their chromosomes changed from zwzz to
ww resulting in the eventual deaths of
the reptiles when nematodes which are
either male or hermaphroditic were
exposed no males were produced during
the experiment male nematodes changed
and became hermaphroditic and the
hermaphroditic specimens were completely
unaffected as far as the researchers
could tell earthworms that were exposed
to the stone were not transformed at all
and the transformation process stopped
during stage two every single time
several of the previously mentioned
animals were used as test subjects as
well in order to determine what effect
the stone would have on a creature that
already naturally changes its sex
characteristics clownfish exposed to the
stone experienced no change to their sex
characteristics but bizarrely did change
color from white and orange to a vivid
blue no adverse effects were identified
bearded dragons exposed to scp-113
spontaneously began to lay eggs which
were immediately retrieved and placed
into incubators for observation
once hatched the eggs contained ordinary
baby bearded dragons that seemed to have
no altered physiology or residual
effects from the stone the hawkfish
exposed to the stone simply transformed
the same way they would in the wild from
female to male just at a faster rate
than they would under natural
circumstances the rest of the animals
tested had the same result as the
earthworm the stones simply disengaged
from the test subject during stage two
of the transformation as if it was
giving up as scp-113 is classified as
safe and only impacts those who
deliberately come into physical contact
with it its containment procedures are
relatively simple the stone is kept in
standard storage at site-23 and may be
handled with laboratory gloves no living
being is permitted to be exposed to
scp-113 unless it has been officially
approved if exposed to scp-113
personnel must be kept under medical
observation for seven days in order to
study its impact and make sure no
unexpected adverse effects are present
after conducting a variety of animal
trials the research team assigned to
scp-113 became curious yet again about
its impact on human test subjects not on
new subjects but those that had already
been transformed by scp-113
in one way or another they wanted to
determine what would happen to someone
who was re-exposed to the stone would it
reverse its own effects essentially
turning them back to the person they
were before the experiment would it
transform them further would it harm
them in an attempt to find out several
of the original d-class personnel used
in 113's human trials were brought back
for another round of experimentation as
well as a new d-class to test the
effects of immediate re-exposure first
the d-class who had never been exposed
to scp-113 had the stone placed on his
bare arm immediately it attached itself
to him and the transformation began
after the transformation was complete
and the rock detached from his arm the
attending scientists waited a duration
of 60 seconds before reattaching it in
order to avoid excessive tissue damage
the stone was placed on his other arm
for a second trial almost immediately
the subject began to cry out in immense
pain writhing on the exam table and
begging for the stone to be removed of
course at this point it had already
bound to his cells and could not be
taken off during stage two his liver
began to swell and he began to enter the
early phases of kidney failure by the
time stage four was complete and the
stone could be removed the subject had
passed out from the pain an immediate
physical examination determined that the
subject had significant damage to his
liver and kidneys as well as a loss of
bone density and massive tissue damage
on the arm where the stone had been
placed finally his genitals appeared to
have completely disappeared leaving a
smooth surface behind on the pubic area
like that of a doll the subject died a
few hours later from organ failure and
internal bleeding the rest of the
d-classes were understandably reluctant
to be re-exposed to the stone but
unfortunately for them and luckily for
the foundation they didn't have much of
a choice well that's brutal security
locked the door to the examination room
and the experimentation proceeded as
planned re-exposure after a significant
amount of time had passed had a much
higher success rate than immediate
re-exposure and the rest of the test
subjects survived their second
transformation at the hands of
scp-113 however it did not return them
to the state they were in before their
first exposure to the stone some of them
experienced no physical changes at all
save for a small amount of tissue damage
where the stone touched their skin
others experienced physical changes that
had nothing to do with their sex
characteristics one subject's eyes
changed color from green to purple while
another subject suffering from male
pattern baldness emerged from the
experiment with a full head of hair some
of the changes were more dramatic one
subject ended up with feathers sprouting
all over the surface of her skin another
lost all of his teeth one particularly
odd test subject seemed completely
ordinary and unchanged until his
physical examination during the exam it
was discovered that all of his internal
organs had changed places inside of his
body their configuration turned
completely upside down he seemed
otherwise unharmed and able to function
as normal and still works at the
foundation to this day even when
exposure is spaced out the more times a
person comes into contact with scp-113
the stranger the effects get the details
have been expunged from the official
foundation file but there are rumors
that one test subject after their fifth
exposure to scp-113
transformed into something completely
inhuman and possibly deadly like i said
the details have been removed from the
file but word gets around especially
words like claws and acid tentacles
those could just be rumors but who knows
biology is full of mysteries and there
is still so much we do not understand
about the natural world and the ways in
which living things can transform for
better or for much worse perhaps some
mysteries especially the mystery of
scp-113
are better left alone now go check out
scp-004
12 rusty keys and the door and scp-500
panacea for more unusual object scps